[Music]
time shares
oh i just got a little throw up in my
mouth when i said it
time shares if you've been ripped off or
locked in one of those rooms
or someone you love has been ripped off
by a timeshare company
you know what that makes you typical
most people have it's a horrible
business
they have absolutely zero value you know
what a time share is worth when you try
to sell it
zero you actually have to pay to get rid
of it
and you go on vacation
and you're so cheap that you thought you
were going to beat them up
and they say we'll give you a free hotel
room
if you will just come to the sales
presentation
and then they lock you in the sales
presentation with no food no water and
no bathroom
breaks for six hours literally does
happen
until you surrender because your blood
sugar is so low that your brain quits
working and you buy
one of the dumbest things on the planet
called a timeshare
even going to one of those meetings is a
dumb thing
signing up to get a free hotel room that
isn't that great to start with
in return for giving up six hours of
your soul
is a dumb thing don't do
that that's like going over to the zoo
and they say
we'll give you a year's pass if you go
into the cage with the tiger and pet him
for an hour oh by the way he's not eaten
in
three days he's a greedy animal and he
will chew
on your head he will likely not allow
you to pet him
you will die and you go oh no for a free
pass to the zoo for a year i'll try
petting the tiger
because i can pull it off and you go in
and you come out without your arm and
then you're shocked
because the tiger ate your butt well
that's what happens the aarp
says the top 10 scams
that cost older americans the most
money number one way
the elderly is scammed romance
scams 83 million dollars lost last year
number seven out of the list of the ten
scams that take money from the elderly
according to the aarp
timeshares 17.4 million
number 10 trying to sell
the timeshare 12.5 million
which by the way together is 30 million
dollars that the elderly have been cost
last year
in late december diane burkhardt sent a
complaint to the fbi describing our 88
year old father agreed to purchase
250 000 worth of timeshare points over
the course of 18 months
he was diagnosed with dementia during
this time
he's now 89 and living in a nursing home
and the couple of course purchased the
points from
diamond resorts international one of the
grossest of all the timeshare companies
who has just been purchased or is in
agreement to be purchased by hilton
for 1.4 billion dollars
hilton you're getting ready to screw up
a really good brand by swallowing this
rat i know you think you're swallowing
this rat but you're going to get
indigestion when you do hilton
it's going to cause you a problem as a
matter of fact there are activists
shareholders trying to prevent the sale
because they do not want
hilton to buy diamond resorts
her father 87 at the time enjoying a day
trip to the beach with his wife at a
town about 30 miles from their house
in central california and they came
across a charming hotel
unbeknownst to them the property was
hotel california no i'm kidding
it would you know you know you can leave
you can but you can't you can come in
but you really can't leave you don't
have
been purchased by diamonds sales people
standing outside the property lured the
old
interested couple into a timeshare sales
pitch
she writes that they immediately
regretted the purchase a month after
purchasing the first contract my
dad tried to end the agreement due to
his wife's declining health
and included a letter diamond turned him
down so he paid off the promissory note
in full believing that would be the end
of it
it was only the beginning shortly
thereafter diamond told them they needed
to go to a meeting to learn how to use
their points
the meeting turned out to be another
lengthy sales pitch
250 000 later
they owned a bunch of points to diamond
oh by the way he had dementia
turn it over to the fbi who's
investigating
it's not the first time consumers have
described possible elder abuse
in the timeshare industry which was
reinventing its business model in recent
years
yeah sales are down timeshares used to
be tied to a specific property where
people owned a partial deed
and had the right to vacation for a set
amount of days a year but in recent
years the industry has instead
switched over to the points concept just
kind of like those airline miles you get
with your credit card you ever tried to
use them dadgum near impossible